they said spicy i'm making it spicy the
biggest challenge to making this dish is
to please read i would say it comes down
the flavor it has nothing to do with me
it's all about the ingredients
drama
hi guys i'm ruiz usually i make it fancy
but i'm challenging three cooks spice up
the dish for me and let's see what it's
the mystery ingredients
blood bread i love bread like oprah
and fly bread is one of my favorite i
usually order flat bread when i go to
mediterranean restaurant indian
restaurant
it's fluffy and soft i'm looking for
something i've never seen before they
have only 45 minutes to impress me
afterwards i'm going to choose the
winner and i don't know who cooked what
let's see food that's the best job to
spice it up
hey guys i'm jasmine and today i'm going
to be making a garlic veggie flatbread
so today i'm doing flatbread art you've
seen focaccia art i'm trying to do it on
flatbread i've never done it before but
really would like something artsy
something unique and still true to the
dish which is flatbread i hurt my thumb
earlier so that's one thing that's
keeping me
thumbs up though
i'm keeping it simple first i'm going to
add in all my dry ingredients my flour
baking powder sea salt just gonna whisk
this together i'm gonna make a little
well in the middle add in olive oil some
maple syrup you can also use sugar if
you want and the water i'm gonna add
most of it but not all of it so i'm just
gonna mix it together until it becomes a
workable dough and then i'll take it out
and knead it the art of flatbread really
lies in its simplicity i feel like if
you're making it too complicated and it
becomes a pizza then you're no longer
making a flatbread and that art of the
flatbread is now gone the heart of it
you know i'm going to cover this up
leave it for about 10 minutes and then
we can get to decorating now i'm going
to make the sauce very simple i'm just
going to combine some garlic and some
olive oil mix that together now that
it's been 10 minutes the dough is ready
i'm just going to separate these into
even dough balls my finger it hurts
if really were here she would not only
know that this is the best flatbread
recipe but it's also the most fun to
make all right i'm just rolling them out
i'm not worried about the actual shape
of my canvas i kind of like this rustic
look and the art is going to be made
with the veggies so for this flatbread i
had a whole scenario in my head you know
perhaps you're at a candlelit dinner but
first comes out the flatbread it should
be a show-stopping entrance a wowza i'm
just rolling it out to be about a fourth
to an eighth inch thick if you were a
spice what would you be do condiments
count as spices if i were a spice i
would say sesame oil because when you
add sesame oil it takes you to the next
dimension let's brush on this garlic oil
this is the exciting part one of my
special ingredients on my flatbread is
corn i feel like corn is such a
transformative ingredient and when you
add it to anything it adds that like
vibrancy so you get like a little bit of
pop some juiciness some sweetness it
just makes everything taste so good so
for my flat red art i'm gonna be making
some plants on there let's lay down the
flowers first now i'm adding some yellow
bell pepper as the petals of this flower
fun fact i actually don't like cilantro
it just tastes too bitter i'm done with
the first one i
am a plant mom with lots of plants and
lots of flowers at home so i'm hoping
that when she sees it she gets a similar
feeling that i get when i look at my
plants which is tranquility and
happiness my flatbreads are ready i'm
going to throw this in the oven at 400
for about 10 minutes i'm pretty excited
to see how they turn out while these are
baking in the oven i'm gonna make my
green sauce this sauce is freaking
impeccable okay there's this place in
the bay area when i went to college
there was this place that always served
their bread and their pizzas with this
green sauce in fact if they were out of
green sauce that day i wouldn't go
that's how good this sauce was i'm
adding in some parsley some green onions
some sprigs of dill i'm just gonna mince
this in the processor
and key ingredient here anchovies very
very important garlic capers drained and
lemon juice while that's going i'm going
to pour in a steady stream
of olive oil
oh my gosh so good black pepper some
salt just one more i feel like anchovy
just really gives the sauce that umami
that you're looking for
so good we're done my flatbreads are
done i've gone ahead and plated them the
sauce is here riya can rip up the
flatbreads dip as she pleases i hope she
likes it
hey everybody my name is seth and today
i'm making coconut chicken curry
flatbread with wasabi crema so this is a
really quick recipe but what it lacks in
time that it takes it more than makes up
for it in flavor the first thing we want
is some full fat coconut milk then we're
gonna add to that some mild thai red
curry paste we're gonna add to that some
lime juice some fish sauce about a half
a cup of granulated sugar some grated
ginger some chopped garlic cloves some
salt some pepper so we're like halfway
done already the only thing we want to
do with this is good whisk to make sure
that everything's evenly incorporated so
we're going to take our pound of chicken
thighs they're frankly better than every
other part of the chicken and i'll fight
whoever says otherwise we're gonna add
some diced yellow onion and then a cup
of chicken stock so i'm gonna add this
to our chicken thighs the beautiful
thing about cooking with a pressure
cooker is all of that moisture all of
this liquid is going to stay in the pot
it's not going to evaporate i'm going to
close the lid and then we're going to
set it to high and then we're going to
just let that cook for 20 minutes let's
move on to the next steps so this is my
wasabi crema it's only four ingredients
so we're gonna start off with some
mexican crema that is velvety so you can
either do wasabi sauce if you're
familiar with it it's usually in asian
markets or you can do wasabi paste if
you're doing wasabi paste like we have
here you want to be very sparing with it
because this stuff is pungent to that
we're going to add some lemon juice and
one of my favorite ingredients that i
use in just about everything we're going
to grate one clove of
garlic i think we could stand to put
just a little more in there and then
we're gonna get started on step three so
we're gonna take some watermelon radish
like we have here and they're thinly
sliced like potato chips and just slice
them into little ribbons and to that
we're gonna add some thinly sliced red
onion and then one of my favorite
favorite ingredients i love cilantro i
cannot get enough so we're just gonna do
a rough chop on these for all of you out
there in youtube land who are watching
this right now i was sharing with the
crew that every single production i've
been on every time i cook with chili's
on camera i always end up rubbing my
eyes and we have to break for like 30
minutes but because i only have 45 here
i'm not gonna do that the spice level is
probably and it all depends on the
chilies because sometimes you'll get
thai chilies that are nice and mild and
just have like a bit of the kick and
then you'll get another batch of thai
chilies that will literally kick you in
the mouth so the spice level could be
anywhere from a four to an eight but it
shouldn't exceed n8 the very last thing
we want to do for our salad that we're
gonna top my flat bread with is we're
gonna drizzle a little olive oil and
then we're just gonna give our salad a
little toss you see it's nice and
colorful and we're just gonna move on to
the next step which is our flat bread so
we're gonna get started by just dumping
the rest of our olive oil then i got my
trusty dusty garlic clove grate that
down give it a good stir so i'm just
going to take the pastry brush and brush
this garlic oil this quick garlic oil
all over my flat bread so our flat bread
is garlic oiled up our grill pan is nice
and screaming hot then i'm gonna take my
baby tongs here we're just gonna toss it
on i really just want to give the flat
bread a good char should only take maybe
60 seconds for each side i can already
smell the garlic if i was a spice what
would i be i'd be the whole seasoning
aisle at your favorite local grocery
store only the ones that have like an
international section to it too because
i can't just be stuffed with salt and
pepper i was raised on just about
everything and my mom raised me on
japanese food i grew up with a bunch of
filipino friends we all grew up on
chinese food so everything that i i eat
and cook usually has some type of asian
influence in it we've got some charred
flat bread some good char marks on them
we're just gonna sprinkle some fontina
it's really creamy and it's delicious
all right so our oven's preheated so i'm
just gonna pop this in the oven until
the cheese starts to bubble until the
cheese on the outside layers start to
get a little crispy so let's do that
alrighty guys we got all the fixings i'm
just going to get started with assembly
now we've got our coconut curry chicken
we're just going to place a little bit
on each slice we're going to take our
crema just kind of spoon some over top
and finally beautiful salad to add to
each for some crunch for some freshness
isn't she a beaut this is my coconut
curry chicken flatbread with wasabi
crema i hope riya loves it i hope i
destroyed the competition respectfully
of course but destroyed nonetheless
[Music]
hi i'm alex and today i'm gonna be
making trinidad doubles it's one of the
most popular street foods in trinidad
it's a spicy fried flatbread dough and
it's gonna be delicious okay we're gonna
start with the baros which is the fried
flatbread part super simple i'm adding
in flour cumin our yeast
salt turmeric white pepper and sugar i
really wanted to make something today
that was going to be a little different
i didn't want to do just like a plain
flatbread this popped in my mind because
i've had it a couple of times but i've
never made it so i'm hoping that i don't
mess it up so now i'm going to put a
little water i can eat so much flat
bread like if i'm ever at a restaurant
oh my gosh and they have a flatbread i'm
going to get the flatbread i just love
bread i can't go on and on
i think i have an advantage just knowing
really so well but then i also have a
disadvantage and like i haven't made
this before so it could go wrong we
don't have to knead it too long just a
couple minutes to get a nice smooth
dough ball consistency
let's make the dough a little
so now i have a clean bowl i'm gonna put
a little bit of oil rub that around the
dough is gonna rise in this bowl pop a
little towel over there all right so
let's let this rise and get into the
chickpeas okay moving on to our spicy
chickpeas or chana a lot of spice is
going into this one but it's still super
simple first i'm gonna add in a little
bit of oil pan is over medium heat we're
doing cayenne paprika allspice nutmeg
dried thyme curry powder chicken
bouillon white pepper and last but not
least cumin they said spicy i'm making
it spicy if i was a spice i would be
cayenne
red hot now that that's going i'm adding
in our white onion
i think i got some spices in my nose
man i'm sweating it's hot in here i'm
gonna add in my garlic never too much
garlic in my opinion all right now i'm
gonna go in with our chickpeas i hope
riya likes chickpeas i think she does
give that a mix okay now i'm going to
add in my stock this is going to be kind
of like a stew almost i'm throwing in a
habanero today i didn't cut it open
because that's going to be another level
of spice but i'm just going to let it
kind of like infuse into our stew i'm
also going to add in some of our green
onions this is not skimping on flavor
i'll tell you that i'm just going to add
a little salt and fresh parsley
it's so good
it's real a little spicy but she's gonna
love it and now i'm just gonna let this
cook down a little bit thicken up and
that's artana
our dough has doubled now i'm just gonna
punch it down with my hand wow this has
a great color too so now i'm just going
to portion this out we want little dough
balls that we're gonna fry up so first
i'm just gonna cut it in half okay now
i'm just gonna roll these dough babies
into a ball i'm also gonna cover these
with the towels so they don't dry out
while i'm rolling out the rest of them
before kneading the dough you take out
your aggressions when you roll the dough
you just kind of like meditate a little
i guess i'm just going to flatten it go
in for a circle shape because this is
going to puff up in the hot oil when we
fry it all right we're ready to fry our
oil is at 350 degrees pop it in the oil
very carefully of course so these fry up
really quick like 30 seconds each side
looking really good it's puffing up okay
i'm gonna flip it over other side
there's our first i'm gonna do another
one this is such a fun street food snack
next one is done time to plate i am
going to do two of the fried doughs so
i'm just gonna take our one piece of
fried dough the barra and then top it
with our chana beautiful that is our
doubles from trinidad i hope riya likes
this sure did spice it up
[Music]
everything looks amazing i'm going to
start with this this kind of look like a
pizza
i love the flavor combination i think
wasabi crema works really well i love
this fresh radish and red onion chicken
is so tender and juicy i really like
this dish next nice dipping sauce
i like the bread it's fluffy as i like
there's a lot of flavor with this
dipping sauce like a lot of like herbs
and acid it's beautiful on your eyes and
it's delicious on your tongue next it's
a little bit different
nice like spice has a stick to it i love
this flap but it's like bright color and
so fluffy i like this bread a lot so we
are going to bring back the cooks and we
are going to reveal the winner
it was very difficult to choose the
winner but i've made my decision that we
not eat
[Music]
congratulations that's awesome
i think the flavor combination totally
worked i like this dish a lot can i eat
it
right yeah i want some
first i would like to thank the academy
but everyone did a great job thank you
so much for spicing up a dish for me you
know what they say about guys with big
forks right oh my god they have really
big kitchens
today was so much fun we ate a lot we
laughed a lot but maybe you guys should
let us know what we should uh spice up
next time let us know in the comments
yay
[Music]
you